climate change is one of the big topics
that today's g20 summit researchers say
is one of the reasons that tiny island
off the east coast is washing away
Tangier Island is home to about 500
people and people's there say erosion is
the biggest problem and they want the
president's help before it's too late
the island sits in the Chesapeake Bay
it's only one in a quarter square miles
and gets smaller every year
chip Reid visited visited Tangier Island
and joins us from the banks of the
Potomac River chip good morning
well good morning yes the Potomac River
is a tributary of the Chesapeake Bay
where climate change caused by
greenhouse gas emissions is part of the
problem but the people of Tangier Island
say islands have been washing away in
the bay for hundreds of years long
before the Industrial Revolution they
say there's only one thing that's going
to save their home they want President
Trump to build them a wall Tangier
Island in the middle of the chesapeake
bay rises only a few feet above the
surrounding waves an hour by boat from
the mainland about 500 people live here
since the 1600s residents have survived
on the bounty of the bay Tangier
produces an estimated 13% of the bays
prize to blue crabs more than any other
town in Virginia James Eskridge is the
mayor of Tangier his family has been
here for generations they've watched it
gradually sink under the waves if we get
a severe nor'easter or something you can
make a mark where the shoreline is and
after the storm you go I've learned to
markcaswell offshore it's happened since
1850 the island has lost 66 percent of
its land in about a hundred years it's
all expected to be under water
evacuation of the island could begin in
the next two decades researchers say one
cause is rising sea level due to climate
change but Tangiers more immediate
problem is something called wave induced
erosion
the island is literally being washed
away by the waves and will eventually
disappear we need help from the erosion
if we just sea level rise that we were
worried about we would be in good shape
help looks like this a rock wall this
one was built on the islands western
side in the 1980s the erosion here
stopped now they say their only hope is
a wall around the entire island but it
will cost an estimated 20 to 30 million
dollars which they don't have they'd
like Congress to approve the money and
Mayor Eskridge thinks President Trump
could help cut through all the red tape
he's gonna cut back on the time it takes
to do studies for these projects we
don't have that time to play with do you
think if the president told Congress I
want to save Tangier Island it would be
safe I do I do indeed
eighty-seven percent of the islands
residents voted for mr. Trump Eskridge
says that's in part because of his
pledge to cut federal regulations in
June the president took notice of the
islands support and gave the mayor a
call we have been discussing sea-level
rise and they said Tangier has been here
for hundreds of years and it would be
from here for hundreds more the
president's call triggered other calls
to the island but these were different
some condemned the people here for
seemingly agreeing with the president's
controversial view of climate change he
has called it a hoax
one business received this message it
was disheartening and it was upsetting
Laurie Thomas who works for the town
said one man called to say that she and
the people on the island deserved to die
I think it lit a fire under everybody
again to push and to contact our
congressman and try to save this time to
try to save the island Thomas says
saving Tangier would mean preserving a
rare and special way of life a place
where parents let their children roam
free to play in the streets and swim at
the docks
regardless of whether climate change is
man-made
you need something to happen tomorrow
yeah we're to the point now that we we
need help immediately
we've been studied and now we're to the
point the islands going down we we just
need to help you come now
as you heard mayor Eskridge is tired of
studies of Tangier Island he says the
last study took twenty years and that's
about the amount of time they might have
before they have to start leaving the
island
Gail alright listen nobody deserves to
die because of who you voted for you do
hope that somebody can do something to
help what's happening there at and your
own there not making more land well it's
actually the story earlier in the week
in North Carolina about the island being
created that's right as you see more
activity at sea you'll see both of this
on yeah that's right reporting thank you
chip